[Music]
what's going on guys so you know we love
the big tent pole box-office behemoths
we talk about them all the time but
today we're going to take it down a
notch we're going to talk about some
hidden gems maybe some movies that
you've heard of maybe some movies that
you've actually seen great but stuff
that's a little bit off the beaten path
with another episode of the best movies
that you've never seen and we've got a
couple of great film lovers here first
she's a great friend of the show you
seen her all over screen junkies and
she's a host on film struck Alicia
Malone
no thanks having me this guy oh he's a
good friend he's a super funny stand-up
comedian and an actor you could see him
on the new Twin Peaks and he's got a
recurring part on better call Saul josh
Batum hi hi hi we're a bunch of big
movie lovers we're going to talk about
some of our favorite films so Alicia
talk to us about one of the films well
I'm going to start with one that you can
see right now it's on video on demand
it's called raw or how do you say it in
American accent raw raw it's a French
film by director Julie dough Cano is her
directorial debut and it's super
impressive
it's a cannibal coming-of-age story a
girl coming into her own power a girl
discovering herself sexually at college
but she goes to study to be a
veterinarian she has to go through this
rite of passage kind of hazing ritual at
college involving eating rabbit so she
gets a taste for meat and then she gets
a taste for human meat but it's also
about female relationships and sibling
rivalry so much going on there so I
highly recommend checking out raw
awesome
thanks Alicia Josh talked to us about
one of the films you like the film belly
directed by hype Williams from late 90s
I think it is visually amazing and it's
shot by some photographer Malik Sahid
who was Spike Lee's cinematographer for
years it stars a nas and DMX yeah Method
Man and tirole Hicks
Method Man a friend of screen junkies
you recognized me
you lovely as soon as I saw him I was
like the guy from screen junkies yes I
am a subscriber wu-tang for life thanks
a lot yeah next time Method Man comes
guy asking about
belli yeah if you want to be sold on
belly just watch the opening where there
they remix soul to soul to this violent
robbery and then it kicks into a kind of
a Goodfellas E narration I'm a movie
that I really like from 2008 from the
director's Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck who
are directing the upcoming Captain
Marvel with brie Larson sugar is this
film that tells a really intimate story
about this minor league baseball player
in the Dominican Republic and it kind of
lays out how the Dominican Republic is
this hotbed of baseball and in order to
get off the island and like improve
their lives it's so competitive to be
scouted by major league Scout it's like
I don't really follow baseball when we
go to a game or whatever but I really
like a good baseball movie yeah right
yeah yeah I like to do this full movie
yeah follow sports at all yeah either
there's like an inherent lack baek's
there I'm the dog story it's a great
it's a cinematic world yeah I mean just
take it from Kevin Costner am i right
yeah I can't stop making it yeah Kevin
yeah right but sugar much smaller film
and just it's such a beautiful journey
this guy goes on and I really connected
with it so yeah check it out Alicia
let's hear about another film you like
all right another coming-of-age story
that I really like is called the fifth
it's the directorial debut by Anna Rose
Hulman and her first film but it's
really impressive and I can't wait to
see more from her this 11 year old girl
she's a tomboy she boxes with her
brother but she watches the dancers and
she wants to be part of this dancing
troupe and so she does but then the
movie takes a really interesting turn
and each of the members of the dance
troupe starts suffering from these
seizures these fits where they they
levitate off the ground and it becomes
very surreal and so you can read into
that as much as you like or you can just
watch how beautiful the story is but I
love the fact that you know indie movies
can do these very simple premises but
then to do a twist on it and make it
something different and the fits is one
that really stuck with me I would like
to check that out now I haven't seen
that again Thank You Josh what's another
one
like Alison Anders film me vida loca
it's an LA set movie which is great
yeah 90s it's about two girls who find
out that they were both seeing the same
guy
and they're both pregnant with his child
and he gets murdered so they hate each
other and then they have to sort of
forge a bond you know that's what Alison
Anders always did really well she did
these 90s indie films showing people
that you didn't see on-screen yes food
lodging all available mother and she was
such a vital part especially for LA
nineties in your name the next one I'm
going to throw out there this is a 1982
film from great director Sydney lament I
feel like on his filmography this gets a
little bit overlooked a film called
the verdict I think it's Paul Newman's
greatest performance he plays basically
this alcoholic down-on-his-luck lawyer
such an antihero they're not even at
they're just an unlikable guy who tries
to resurrect his life and he takes on
this case that no one wants and he's
going to take to trial this malpractice
suit that no one no one thinks he can
win and it's like willy redeem himself
maybe Alicia Leigh another one on us
there was a great Swedish film called
force majeure that came out in 2014 it's
by director Ruben Oakland who just won
the major prize at the Cannes Film
Festival with the square which is a
movie I love but this one is such an
interesting dark comedy it's about a
family who goes on a skiing holiday
there's an avalanche and they each react
to this emergency in different ways so I
give anything away but it's unexpected
and then you have to deal with the
repercussions of that so it makes you
think what would you do in a situation
where you have to choose between saving
a family saving strangers or just saving
yourself I don't know what I do Wow all
right very funny Josh I wanted to
recommend if you haven't seen it
Alejandro Jodorowsky's dance of reality
which came out and I think 2014 its
first about the story of a little boy
and it turns out the story about the
boy's dad it's just some amazing
surrealist stuff in there his mother
every piece of her dialogue
spoken in Opera so it's hilarious at
first is so weird and then as the movie
goes on you just get used to it that's
just like how he remembers his brothers
that yeah you know like that she was an
operatic type woman yes big bucks and I
just got a weird a serial like feel to
it very cool Josh thanks for the
recommendation got it I'll throw another
one out there this isn't like a super
obscure film probably a lot of you have
seen it but if you haven't seen it you
must this is 1979 the jerk I think well
yeah absolute classic one of my cameras
you know what do you do yeah how are you
living here there are all these other
ones that we talk about get right there
oh yeah it's like day one he hates these
can stay away from my channel one of the
great comedies of all time the world of
this manchild in his journey Steve
Martin the idiocy that he captures is
brilliant one of the things that works
so well about the jerk is that he's an
idiot but he doesn't know it he thinks
he's you're painting this I'm smart I
defy you to see the jerk and a not laugh
and B not start singing the thermos song
and hear it you must see the jerk please
talk to us Alicia
I love the jack okay I'm going to go
with one that I've spoken about many
times it's a girl walks home alone at
night by Anna Lily and we're poor it's
an Iranian western vampire movie oh it's
so unique it's really original all shot
in black and white but it has you know
obvious how much as to Quentin Tarantino
and Dario Argento but at the same time
feels like her own unique style she has
another movie coming out this year
called the bad bats which is a cannibal
film I love my cannibal makeup but
before you see that you should see a
girl walked home alone at night great
excellent thank you Alicia
Josh there's a film called blue sunshine
came out in the 70s in Los Angeles
there's a series of murders of going on
happening by people who kind of turn
into maniacs and they lose their hair
and what it turns out is that all these
people experimented with a particular
strand of LSD in the hippie era and now
it's coming back to haunt them and
they're turning into May
accent killing people blue sunshine was
name of the drug dollar doing yeah
pretty fun I haven't seen one it's fun
and it's crazy-looking visually
instructed by Jeff Lieberman who made
some pretty good horror movies okay I'll
throw it out there I saw this movie in
college and it kind of blew my mind down
by law it's a black and white film Tom
Waits John Laurie Roberto Benigni it's a
fun stupid story about three guys who
like shouldn't be hanging out together
they get stuck in prison and then they
break out of prison and they're on the
run so it's a little bit of a kooky
slapstick journey but it's also just so
subtle and epitomizes school with so
many of its scenes and the dialogue and
the way New Orleans is shot and the
Bayou it's a beautiful little film and
super badass great page thankfully I'm
gonna go with one that's just really fun
and easy to watch it's called the one I
love directed by Charlie McDowell and it
shows how how you can do with sci-fi
premise really simply in an indie film
with very few cast members and very few
locations it stars Elisabeth Moss and
Mark Duplass and they play a couple
whose therapist suggests that they go to
a house for the weekend because they're
having troubles in their marriage and I
won't say what happens when they go to
this house but basically they each find
their ideal partner there's not in a way
that you expect it it's just a really
fun easy intriguing watch and the kind
of movie that you want to talk about
with your friends makes a bit of a wild
turn a little a boiler yeah the one I
love great Josh I would like to suggest
Buster Keaton the cameraman which is one
of my favorite Buster Keaton films and
what I'll say about it it's a his
penultimate silence he made it under
contract with MGM so he couldn't do
things in the process that he usually
does he couldn't do all the crazy set
pieces he couldn't workshop him on set
so he had to have it all scripted out so
there's actually very little set pieces
but he's just so fantastic and slick and
beautiful looking because they had that
MGM studio budget he's physical comedy
and stuff he was able to do without
saying a word I mean it's incredible and
he has such an influence on so many
comedians in the way that he brings his
motions into it the rage it brings it
with this you know with his body in his
face very cool and the movies got a lot
of heart I'll say that movie has a lot
of hearts very sweet right yeah I've got
one more film that I really like I saw
this one as a kid I was like whoa this
is an awesome action adventure talking
about Capricorn one a great adventure so
much fun James Brolin Josh Brolin's dad
yeah and Elliott Gould classic 70s
actors fun fact that the film features
OJ Simpson among other people it's about
the faking of the landing on Mars okay
so for you conspiracy theorists it's
right up your alley man and so if the
government has a Mars mission they fake
it but then they can't let the secret
that they faked it ever get out and they
have to kill the astronauts who are in
this soundstage filming it and they
escape and man what a rollicking journey
check it out if you can find it Alisha
Josh this is super fun thank you for
these suggestions and I want to thank
you for watching so what are some
undiscovered little-known gems that you
love that you feel like oh people need
to be turned on to these and which of
our movies have you seen or what do you
look forward to seeing let us know in
the comments below we want to know again
guys thank you for hanging out and
talking movies with us thanks again for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter
bye-bye thanks al
[Music]